okay so so that was the cinematography s
our next category is film editing oh we
know all about film editors they're the
ones who like to cut out a lot of my
lines oh yeah yeah they did a real
number on me this year did you know that
I was originally in 1917 No
yeah yeah and parasite oh my god yeah a
wonderful year I know well listen to
this it was originally Ford versus
Ferrari versus Farrell what yes
what and I'm still know a lot of the key
art unbelievable I'm just gonna say it I
hate this one oh yeah it's it's a no
home boy oh hello hello oh yes I'm here
yeah no no no so you do have one oh no
he is he's about to say that I'm only
saying he's saying it dear are the
nominees for achievement in film editing
yeah he just did it
Ford versus Ferrari Michael McCusker and
Andrew Buchan
the Irish made Thelma Schoonmaker Jojo
rather Tom Eagles Joker
Jeff gross
aracite young junior and the Oscar goes
to Michael McCusker and Andrew Botwin
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for Andrew Buckland this is also the
first win and second
for Michael McCusker
Wow hello
like to thank the Academy into all the
fellow nominees incredible work we
wouldn't be here without our stellar
picture crew and arts that's outstanding
sound team as well
it's my amazing and beautiful wife Maria
and our son Lucas I love you so much the
quiero mucho e2 my sister Claire and Joe
and to Armando to my mom and dad who
supported me from the very beginning I
love you so much in my family in
Argentina on base so good I'm named
James mangled James mangled I I just
it's my Blake great pleasure to have sat
and watched you become one of the best
directors in this business in the last
15 years
thank you so much to a great ensemble
cast led by Matt and Christian our DP
Faden Papa Michael our producers Draenor
topping and Peter Chernin to everyone at
20th century the tireless Aaron downing
Ted Galliano Steve as Belle and the
inimitable Emma Watts and finally to my
daughter Elena I love you so much I love
you Baba thank you so much for this
[Applause]
[Laughter]